[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth
do work that they actually love and
create real
amazing relationships this is a show
about your life and your money christina
ellis ramsey personality is my co-host
today the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five joe's in lansing michigan to start
off this hour hey joe what's up
hey dave it's honor to speak with you
you too how can we help
so i'm a little nervous to say this uh
to dave ramsey himself but i typically
use credit cards for all my day-to-day
transactions oh what i know i know
i'm actually wanting to switch over to
cash but every time i do switch to
spending with cash it seems like i
actually spend more even if i do stay
within my budget for example if i'm like
at the grocery store and i have say 50
left in my budget towards the end of the
month um if i'm using cash and it's
sitting there in my envelope i'll go and
grab a couple stakes maybe a you know
case of beer or something whereas if i'm
using a credit card already knowing that
i've racked up
400 bucks on this month's statement it
really keeps me away from
you know spending that little extra
money and making that statement hurt
that much more when it comes in the mail
so my question is basically how can i
kind of get over that mental hurdle and
switch to using cash so i don't have to
do business with people like visa and
mastercard
[Laughter]
okay
well the um
the the principle of this whole thing
the old grandma's old envelope system
and if you have a grocery envelope and
you have the money for your grocery
budget in the envelope you can't spend
that money on anything except groceries
and you can't spend
uh you know it's all and when it's empty
you quit buying and so your problem is
you're ending up with money left over
which means you might be over funding
the envelope
okay
you might be over you might be over
funding the category but the overall
idea behind the thing is
and uh is that we figured out years ago
at ramsey that personal finance is 80
behavior
and so when we can do things that create
friction
that create
mental and emotional recognition of
spending
then it tends to lower and control
spending within a category so for
instance a more sophisticated version of
that is on a website if you have to
click too many times and do too many
hoops to make make the purchase people
will bail on the cart
yeah i've done that plenty of times jump
out because there's too much friction
the opposite end of that is amazon prime
you click buy now and it's on your porch
in an hour or two you know and so that's
the ultimate and low friction situation
but what we what the research tells us
and research done by mit is that when
people spend cash it activates the pain
centers of their brain
when you spend plastic it does not
and i've heard you say that yeah but
it's not it's not working with you for
some reason i don't know what's wrong
with your brain but
right right
so i don't care i don't care what i
would tell you to do if you want to is
uh switch to a debit card
not a credit card
and that's coming out of your checking
account and that way there's no chance
that you accidentally overspend a
category and end up in debt
and then if you want to do that that's
fine
years ago i did that for instance with
the gas pump
when i started teaching this you still
had to go inside the store to pay for
your gas
that i mean this 35 years ago right
and now and then they put those things
at the pump where you don't even have to
walk inside and you stick your cart in
there and
you know what's interesting is the up
evil on high gas prices when you had to
walk in the store and pay cash the
political
uh
firestorm was much higher
because people noticed what they were
paying but when you don't even have to
walk inside and you just put your little
card in there and the only aggravation
is you see a large number but that's the
only thing then the political firestorm
associated with high gas prices isn't as
high uh because they really string the
president up the first time it went to
five dollars and we all paid cash
now it's just kind of like yeah well
it's one of those things and so uh but
that's what's going on so i would use
your debit card christine you got a
suggestion yeah i'm curious you said
that you'll walk into the grocery store
sometimes with 50 and then go get some
steaks and a case of beer that sounds
like more than fifty dollars have you
had the experience
yeah what kind of cheap steak are you
eating
have you had the experience when you get
to check out and it's more than the
fifty dollars or what's kind of been
your parameters without
i i more met one or the other not both
at the same time yeah that put me over
50 dollars
my default setting is very frugal i'm
i'm well under my means as is i maybe
i'm just you know getting too nitpicky
about it but yeah um
no i think i think you know what amounts
to is you don't get um
uh
you you very seldom were overspending
before you met us
right
and so all we're doing is giving you
some guidelines and some mechanical
processes
so yeah what baby step are you in right
now
um i guess technically i'm in six but
i'm doing more than the 15 in my
retirement
that's awesome
yeah very good it doesn't feel like i'm
in sick [ __ ] i still feel like i'm a
youngin
you know what you need to buy more stuff
you're too cheap
you need to enjoy some of your money
you really i mean i don't have any to
enjoy still i mean i know i'm thinking
you know well you had some left over and
didn't want to buy a steak i mean
so i want you to enjoy some of your
money a little bit at the grocery store
that's okay you don't have to be on
beans and rice at this stage
and so here's the thing a lot of people
most people that we deal with are
spenders in our culture but occasionally
we run into a frugal person like you and
we all have to learn all three
we have to develop all three money
muscles the generosity muscle
the saving investing muscle and the
spending muscle and the spending muscle
means in why spending but doing some we
have to enjoy money
we have to save and invest it we have to
be generous and if you're not doing and
frugal people tend to leave that one off
and spenders tend to not do either one
of the other ones because they just
spend it all on themselves but um but
that that's what we run into right i
don't think that he expected such an
affirming response after calling it
about credit cards
well there is that but yeah yeah i would
chop up the credit card for sure and get
a debit card that's not a question um
and you know we're
anti-credit card here there's just so
many things that can go wrong with the
use of a credit card and the debit card
will do everything the credit card will
do has the same fraud protections i
travel all over the world my debit cards
i don't have any issues with them
that are any of you don't have with your
credit card all of us get the fraud
alert you know sometimes and no no no no
you know and all this and did you buy
three dollars worth of gas in canada
nope i didn't um so something wrong
there that we all get those things right
but uh but but
you know
so i
carry debit cards that's all i carry our
company has debit cards hundreds of them
with our you know our team that travels
and everything else and so uh and they
use cash as well uh we don't have a
company credit card at ramsey none of us
do and we don't even have and i
certainly don't have any at home
although christine a full disclosure
after 30 years of doing this i'm still
trying to get sharon to call it a debit
card what does she call it she still
says hand me the credit card after 35
years of me telling people not to use a
credit card my own wife is a traitor no
i'm kidding now she actually knows what
it is but she just forgets she's like
give me the credit card and i'm like no
don't say that out loud somebody will
hear you you're sharing freaking ramsay
that'll you'll start a rumor
there'll be a whole reddit thread over
you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry it's worth it
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money heather's with us in
richmond virginia hi heather welcome to
the ramsey show
hi dave and christina thanks so much for
taking my call today
absolutely how can we help
um so i
paid my i had student loans starting
from 2012 and i have been actively
paying exactly as i should never went
into deferment um paid all the way
through the pandemic and then decided to
make a lump sum to pay off pay them
completely off in january of 2021.
wonderful i recently found
um but i recently found out that i would
qualify for um that i really likely
would qualify for the ride in student
loan forgiveness
and i'm wondering if there should be any
moral dilemmas or misgivings about this
um because i don't you know i don't need
this many i'm on baby steps four five
and six and so should i have any
misgivings about possibly applying for
the forgiveness
i don't know if i'm allowed to tell you
what your morals are
so i i can tell you where
um
okay so let's talk about a couple of
metaphors all right to kind of walk
alongside this on ethics
a lot of ethics things are
if you if you answer them uh and say
how would i want to be treated if i were
on the other side of this if you're on
the other side of something from another
party then you can look at that that's a
little difficult here because this is
the government you're on the other side
of so
it's kind of like it gives a rip on that
part of it but like you know we tell
people not to use credit cards we're
just talking about that and then we have
sometimes a business owner who's gone
through financial peace university paid
off a bunch of credit cards gotten rid
of all their credit cards only has debit
cards
and
they hate credit cards and they own a
pizza restaurant
now do i is it a moral dilemma for them
to take a credit card
um i tell them it's not a moral dilemma
for them to take a credit card uh
because they don't i'm a public figure i
come out tell people don't use credit
cards
so for me to use a credit card would be
pretty much straight up hypocrisy right
i came out and the state of tennessee
passed this ridiculous lotto a few years
ago and i knew the data on the lotto
before they passed it the data on lottos
if you guys out there don't know is um
the state of tennessee uses a lot of
money to send people to college
okay you get three four thousand dollars
five thousand dollars or whatever if you
live in the state of tennessee towards
your college from the lotto fund however
the lotto is primarily pa played by
people in poor zip codes
so it's pretty much poor people sending
rich people middle class people to
school
and so i i raised hell about that when
they're passing in the state of
tennessee i lost the state passed it
it's been going for a decade or more and
when my kids went to college you know
they qualify for it's not income based
at all
everybody can get the 3 000 bucks so do
i go get the 3 000 bucks no
i'm a public figure that campaigned
against it for me to go take that money
then
would be
hypocritical
but heather on the other hand you're
more like the pizza store owner
you haven't publicly come out and
decried on the front page of the wall
street journal that this whole thing is
a scam and a bunch of freaking
communists run in dc you know you know
like i have right and so you're not in
the same position of the ramsey
personalities
any ramsey personality to take student
loan forgiveness as hard as we've come
out against it would be inconsistent
but but
you know uh
it if our
a young lady 25 years old is a creative
and works somewhere inside of ramsay is
she morally wrong to take the
forgiveness no it's a government program
she didn't steal anything she didn't do
anything wrong it's not uh she's not
being a nerdy well so i don't think you
have a moral
uh thing i also am okay if you decide
you don't want to take it on moral
grounds
either one would be fine with me is what
i'm trying to say i don't know you got a
lot of thoughts about this yeah i've
talked to a lot of people the last
several weeks i've done a lot of
facebook and instagram lives hearing
people's opinions and it's just all over
the place a lot of people are really
upset about it a lot of people are super
excited about it and there's just the
whole whole range of emotions and i
think it's hard because i actually put a
poll out on my instagram to see you know
how people felt and about 80 of the
people that responded had negative
reactions they weren't happy about the
forgiveness and and all of that so i
could understand if maybe your friends
are frustrated about the forgiveness
that you're probably a little bit
hesitant
and i also i think it's okay to say hey
you know i don't know that washington
should have made this decision maybe you
disagree with the decision and also
still go but the decision's been made
and i'm going to go ahead and get the
forgiveness like i think like dave said
it really just depends on your own
morals and what you decide but i think
you can feel multiple emotions at the
same time
be frustrated if you want to be
frustrated about this decision but also
realize the decisions been made um
possibly obviously there's still some
loopholes that have to be gone through
we'll see we'll see but but also still
get the forgiveness i don't think it's
really you know bad if you end up
getting getting some of that money back
yeah and you know i guess another
metaphor and this is probably a little
bit harsh of a metaphor but you know
a lady called in one time that was a
single mom who had lost her job and had
two little kids
and um
you know she said i i'm morally opposed
to welfare but i need to take it to feed
my kids right now and i said well are
you going to take it as a way of life
for the next 50 years no just so i can
find something to work to do and i said
honey that's what welfare is for
go get your kids some food
as a taxpayer that's paying for that i'm
i'm okay with that now do i want to
finance you doing that the rest of your
life no that's not good for you it
steals your dignity
but but i'm not i'm not saying you're
some kind of uh horrible deadbeat single
mom feeding your kid with a welfare
check i mean right uh you know until you
get until you're able to land a job yeah
and so that's the same kind of thing
this is probably that's probably even
more visceral or harsh than this
discussion but um
so yeah i i i i i'm gonna be your friend
either way heather is what i'm saying it
doesn't bother me but i think that
people would judge me
harshly were i to take that or my family
were to take that after i've taken a
public person's stand on it and i think
that would be accurate to judge me that
way
because i think that'd be hypocritical
you see what i'm saying
yeah i um i just was feeling a little
conflicted being that you know i i
on one hand i can think of a lot of ways
that i can you know i have a 529 for my
daughter that i could put that money
into and
i'm adopting next year but then at the
same time i know that i don't need that
money when some so many other people do
that it's really important you're not
taking it from someone that that that
would have gotten it and if you weren't
around
like they're not going to go hey heather
got hers and we're out so joan you don't
get any because heather took it there's
not that's not how the program's going
to work okay so it's just going to be
now i will tell you one other thing to
think about and this is to thoroughly
not answer your question
is i the other thing i do sometimes
particularly when we're dealing with uh
things where i i think i'm i'm feel like
i'm right
on something but i'll just do it anyway
out of kindness or generosity because
and the rule i use on that is
when i'm 82 laying on my death bed am i
which way am i going to be happy i did
this
inside my heart of hearts and my soul
am i gonna be happy i gave this a little
bit more
even though the the server was horrible
but i left a little bit bigger tip i'm
never gonna be mad at myself when i'm 82
laying on my deathbed doing that
but shorten them i might come up later
and go gosh i wish i'd been nicer you
know and so it when in doubt don't kind
of thing and that makes you fur further
conflicted but the the biggest concern i
got about the whole thing is you're
worried about it which kind of means you
shouldn't do it in a way that's what i'm
saying but but that's not a a moral
blanket i would throw over everyone out
there listening to this conversation i
think we've made that clear but yeah um
yeah people are pissed and and
we can wrap it up with this i kind of
don't think it's gonna happen anyway
i really don't because they announced
this and they never told the department
of education anything about it before
they announced it and they never told uh
studentloan.gov and they never told you
know none of the website now the
administrative things there's 33 million
people they've got a process and they
didn't even tell the agencies that are
going to process before they announced
it it kind of makes me think they think
it's not going to happen man but if it
doesn't happen at this point it's going
to be a train wreck oh either direction
we'll see they'll blame it on the
republicans
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care
that's why we call them ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free homeownership
and churchill is here to help go to
their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsay personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage patrick
and kelly are with us hey guys how are
you awesome dave how are you and
christina better than we deserve we're
so honored to have you all where do you
all live we are traveling in from the
richmond virginia area chesterfield
virginia fun that's a nice area welcome
to nashville how much debt have you paid
off 332
000 way to go and how long did this take
just a little bit under six years good
for you and your range of income during
that time we started out about 90 and uh
finished up around 1 30. good what do
you guys do for a living i am a i was a
sales
rep for a company and uh became a
training manager okay i was a prenatal
educator with one of the local health
facilities but i'm now retired oh good
for you way to go
okay 332 000 over six years i'm going to
guess and say that might be your house
it does include the house but i'm
looking at weird people
yes
the house was just about half of it so
wow we had 188 000 of consumer debt whoa
and uh it took us three years to
clean that mess up what in the world did
you borrow on dave i had this red credit
card with the little white circles on it
that uh had about 20 000 on it you were
able to hit the target yes
too many times
hit it and hit it and hit it again
seriously that was how much of the 188
was target
18 yeah 18 000 okay well 10 of it what
was the rest of it uh we had two cars
and uh a bunch of other credit cards we
actually have this
frame that we cut up our credit cards
and put them into we had oh yeah i've
got it on the screen yeah excellent
that's what 32 credit cards looks like
oh
yeah
we share that with our classes that we
uh teach or or coordinate for fpu and
thank you yes it's a big lesson and you
know what not to do with with credit
cards so some guy comes in there with
seven credit cards he don't feel dumb
after seeing that
way to go you guys thank you we also we
also had a 54 000 student loan for our
youngest daughter carly
and dave it's that's a
story in itself uh one night i woke up
and i was like we thought we were
debt-free we we paid off a 90 000 we
thought we were debt free i woke up in
the middle of the night
and i was like we got a
student loan we co-signed for
and
i got up i started googling what would
dave say about cosign student loans
and then at six o'clock in the morning
kelly woke up and i'm like hey we're not
dead free look this is what dave says
she started crying we had thought we
were so close but
we knew that was ours so we
took that on and and hit it with gazelle
intensity also and and that was the last
component of that hundred and eighty
eight thousand wow
well you guys have been getting after it
for a long time yeah i mean this is a
this is a pull yeah so what really
started the journey what lit that fire
to get you guys on the road i have to
let kelly answer that oh that's all on
me
we were gifted by our one of our
daughters um the total money makeover
and i looked at it and
just before she gave us that book i was
doing the bills
and it was ugly i was sick to my stomach
every time i had to rob peter to pay
paul
and it wasn't working so i read your
book in a day and i took it to him and i
said we're in a mess
and we got to figure out how to
how to take care of it i said i want you
to look at you know how what this man
recommends and he looked he says
that's not going to work
he could tell by the cover yeah yeah
exactly
so then he finally sucked it up and said
you know all right let's give it a try
let's do it his way well in the meantime
our church was just um starting some
groups and fpu was listed i signed us up
for him and i didn't tell him oh um i
told him we i
we did sign up for a marriage group so i
said we're gonna we i signed up for two
groups one's a marriage group and the
other one's you know just another group
that we're going to attend
he went reluctantly
by the second class i think he was ready
to teach he was ready to go yeah yeah
you say dave you say if it's not working
my way
then i should try somebody else's way
and i think my pride broke through uh
during that second class and i became uh
open-minded but uh she did she did trick
me into going to fbu and
it was one of the best things that ever
happened to us
that's a good wife right there yes
[Laughter]
i mean six years and over three hundred
thousand dollars that's that's a long
journey and then you had that surprise
with a student loan fifty thousand
dollars how did you stay motivated for
that long yeah the motivation came from
uh teaching or coordinating the fpu
classes uh we we will actually start our
15th class next wednesday you're like
super coordinated yes
and
friends friends that
are here with us
scotty and shelly brian they have been
very supportive throughout the process
they've continued to cheerlead for us
they went through our class in 2019
and uh dave just to share they also just
paid off their house last friday all
right so they are now uh baby step seven
also oh yeah
this is great we got a group right here
man this is fun
you guys are amazing okay after all this
now you wake up at six o'clock in the
morning
and there's not a payment in the world
not even a house payment how old are you
two
so i i'll be
fifth or i just turned 55. how long
y'all been married
33 years have you ever been debt free
before now no
now when you wake up at six in the
morning and you don't have a payment in
the world how does it feel it is so
awesome dave we
we added a uh line item to our budget as
we became debt free it's it's our uh
gift line item so above and beyond
tithing we we now are able to
um bless others and and share yeah yeah
that's the most fun you'll ever have
insurance
you guys are amazing you all are amazing
thank you so much for leading 15
financial peace university classes
sharing this story you guys are
our troopers what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is because
you're experts
staying on budget and being content with
what you have
yeah that's a that was a huge lesson for
me dave
we didn't just try to keep up with the
joneses we actually tried to be the
joneses
and so uh we were living
you know pretending to be wealthy and
now we can actually uh work our way to
truly living
like we should yeah you're on your way
very very cool we talked to a lot of
people who have a ton of consumer debt i
love that you guys paid off the consumer
debt and the mortgage and these people
are looking at six figures of debt
thinking there's there's no way i could
ever do this what would you tell those
people
it's it's all about uh the desire to do
it as well as uh the motivation and uh
together
you know we just put our head down
really focused on on the debt and uh
the budget the budget is so critical and
and being content and being happy to say
you know we this is not us today this is
not for us today we'll we'll get it when
we when time comes no means not yet yeah
that's right right that's for y'all hey
we got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story if you're not already there and
according also a total money makeover
book for you to give away and disturb
some other couple i like that and a
financial peace university one year
membership i'm sure you'll find a good
use for that as super coordinators find
somebody that's deserving that you can
send through that so all of those are
gifts for you to re-gift and uh at our
pleasure and we thank you thank you guys
for sharing we're so proud of y'all
you're amazing thank you you're heroes
man you did it yeah baby this is how it
works patrick and kelly richmond
virginia 332 000 paid off in six years
making 90 to 130 debt-free house and
everything
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three
two one
[Applause]
wow
wow
well what's the moral of the story the
moral story is you
can do this if you're listening to this
right now you're watching this right now
you can do this it's very
doable
it's hard
but it's doable this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
christine alice ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five joe is with us in
orlando florida hi joe welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave uh huge fan thanks for having me
how are you today better than i deserve
what's up in your world
yeah so well i want to say thanks to
that last couple for the great testimony
and for being the toughest act to follow
ever
but uh
so uh you know my good news is that
leading up into 2020 completed all the
baby steps i was really rolling have up
to
75k in retirement funds as a 32 year old
um
in 2020 i got married and then we both
got master's degrees so my my big downer
is that we actually now have 85k in
student loan debt
and
when i talk to the very you know
successful people they tell me well you
should start paying that off but also no
matter what contribute to your 401k so
you get the match
um but i have a feeling you're going to
tell me that i should completely
stop contributing to that 401k to pay
off the the debt
why do you have that feeling
well
i've i've watched you i've watched you a
few a few times but i i haven't had to
revisit the uh the the dave ramsey
scriptures since 2020 so i i'm i'm
calling to to maybe get a kick in the
butt and uh and and curious what you
would say to those you know wealthy
folks who took that strategy of still
contributing to their 401k while paying
off debt yeah
i would say that they are not as wealthy
as maybe they're projecting themselves
to be or that they're unusual i'll
answer that question first when we
studied the millionaires 10 167 people
who became millionaires 90 of which
became millionaires starting from
nothing they did not inherit money to
make them millionaires meaning they did
this uh they they built wealth the vast
majority of them there were some that
followed the plan you're talking about
but the vast majority of them
uh you know concentrated on getting rid
of debt and then used the freed up
income to build wealth with because your
most powerful wealth building tool is
your income
now can the way you're working it are
you talking about working it work yes it
can the reason that we've had more
success than a lot of people
in
helping people build wealth is not
because of the mathematics of this
discussion
but because of the behavior aspects of
this discussion
and
what we found is
and it kind of runs against my math nerd
brain
but what we found is the psychology of
this whole thing is more important than
the math is you get the psychology right
the math ends up taking care of itself
here's what i mean
very few people
can be consistent and intense
on three things at once
that lack of focus
that lack of
being dialed in on a singular goal
uh causes people to
not accomplish the goal
so it's very difficult to
i'll use something you said get your
master's degree
uh while running 10 marathons in a year
okay
you could they're both they're both
excellent goals they're both there's
nothing wrong with both but it requires
a level of diligence and singularity of
focus to complete herculean tasks
and uh when you screw around with them
you end up not doing the marathons or
not doing the nba or worse not doing
both
because you try to do too many things at
once and so much stuff on your plate and
uh earl nightingale the father of
motivational speaking grandfather
motivationally speaking used to say that
the difficulty of achieving the goal is
not what keeps people from achieving the
goal as often as
uh the things that they try to do while
they're trying to do the goal
and so all of that is my pitch for
singularity of purpose meaning yeah i'm
stopping everything temporarily what's
your household income by the way
uh
about 160 000 a year okay so you're
going to be debt free in under two years
okay yeah if we really behaved ourselves
that well i mean that that's that i'm
presupposing that with this whole
discussion because if you don't behave
yourself and the other people's plan
doesn't work either
i understood yeah i mean i was on a
three-year uh three-year plan given some
you know emergency fund expenses but
yeah you're spending you're still you're
still going out to eat you're still
going on vacations you're still screwing
around
a little bit yeah i mean 160 000 you
ought to be able to find 40 of it
in a year that's two years
really yeah it's pretty wimpy
yeah well i think it feels hard because
you've already worked through the baby
steps and you you got that pride and
that excitement in 2020 of having
everything paid off and now it's kind of
like a drag to have to go back and go oh
man we got to do this again and i love
that you called in knowing what dave's
going to say i mean you you already know
that you got to go back through this you
know that it's gonna be hard you you're
familiar with the work and the effort um
i think it's just really accepting deep
down that that this journey is you know
starting again that you're back in baby
step two and with that i would encourage
you to go back through fpu or maybe even
coordinate a class you know listening to
the last debt free screen you know they
really
helped other people while they were
helping themselves and that produces
motivation so i think the biggest
challenge right now is like deep digging
deep in your soul to figure out you know
how are we going to get that but don't
go lead a class if you're going to keep
doing this other plan okay that'd be
hypocritical
we don't need we don't need coordinators
half but doing stuff okay
so if you're going to have but do it
don't don't do the class that doesn't
work so you know here's the thing joe
you're going to do what you're going to
do you know you're obviously not dumb
people you make almost a couple hundred
thousand dollars a year you both have
graduate degrees you're not dumb people
you just got to decide what the fastest
right way with the highest probability
of success in the shortest period of
time is
our plan has taught 10 million people
and made more millionaires than all your
little friends uh sipping their lattes
talking together put together half so
you just gotta decide who you're gonna
listen to
uh this is not this i'm not a i'm not a
college professor who never made payroll
this is i'm not operating on tenure here
this is real people doing real stuff 10
freaking million people have gone
through financial peace university there
are tens of thousands
more
millionaires all over america
just because they did exactly what we
said to do now you can decide you don't
want to do that and that doesn't mean
you're dumb the other way will work but
the question is what is the fastest
right way
that has the highest probability of
success least probability of failure
along the way
and it is
getting rid of this debt in under two
years completely focusing beans and rice
rice and beans you fell off the wagon
you went 80 000 in debt look in the
mirror and go stupid i gotta fix this
and that's the fastest right way to
address it now you can screw around with
all these other people's plans and you
know you can watch tick-tock and they've
all got an opinion about money but
there's a reason they're on tick-tock
okay so think about it uh you know you
got to look at this you got to figure it
out and uh but you know
here's the thing if i hire a personal
trainer he walks in he's got an eight
pack and i got a keg
i gotta decide if i'm gonna do his plan
or my plan
you know you just gotta decide which one
i'm gonna go with here yeah and i love
what you said about very few people can
be
consistent and intense on three things
at once you can't that is really
powerful i think a lot of people are
seeing all this get rich quick stuff out
in the market now and they think that
they can do all these things and they're
the one that's going to figure out the
strategy of how to invest in all these
cool fancy things and they're gonna pay
off their debt at the same time and then
they wake up five years later and it did
not work yeah yeah i mean it's listen
that's why this whole idea of life
balance is so stupid
it just doesn't work
you don't have a quality life if every
single day is parsed out balanced across
the nine areas of your life your
spiritual walk you know your physical
fitness your marriage your kids your
education your intellect your work life
you know when you spread all those
things out and try to do them all in one
day nothing gets done
you're training for a marathon
your your bible study may end up sitting
to the side a little bit you're trying
to read through the bible on a year you
may not end up hit hitting the street
every day and running five miles every
day and it's nice you're gonna something
something's gonna trade off baby in
order for you to win at the other thing
and over the scope of your life you need
to touch all these areas but in a given
day a given week or even a given season
no you're not supposed to have life
balance well and you'll get to those
goals later and you'll get to building
wealth you'll get to paying off your
house that's going to come in the baby
steps but be willing to make the
sacrifices and do the hard now so that
you can really win with those goals
later live like no one else so later you
can live and give like no one else no
discipline seems pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving in storage studio it's the ramsey
show where debt is dumb cash is king
the paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships christina ellis ramsey
personality is my co-host today we're
going to be joined by you from all
across america as we talk about you
right in front of you we'll talk about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five teddy is with us in
new york city hi teddy how are you
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thank you for having me on the show
again i called you last year to get a
little guidance in terms of my career
and whatnot especially financially um
and just to kind of remind you you told
me to potentially hold off on my masters
um i'm going to be pursuing that due to
the fact that i just got engaged over
the summer and my fiance has one more
year in the same school so we're just
going to finish up our degrees her
undergrad meet grad school and then head
to the beautiful state of florida
but my goal long term is to have a good
career and more importantly to have
financial stability
ideally in the aspect of real estate
passive income and whatnot
i have no real guidance in that regard
so i'd love to get your take on it
what's your masters in
mechanical engineering
and what what career are you pursuing
after this
uh mechanical engineering okay do you
have a job already lined up
i had a couple
for this cut for this year um but like i
said i decided to just get my master's
um it just didn't seem reasonable to
take a job for one year and then you
know head to a different state
okay
in addition to that my
master's degree only cost less than 14k
for the whole program and i'm currently
debt free as well
so
it's something that i can reasonably pay
off while i'm in school that's awesome
how did you pay for your education
um predominantly through scholarships
and some financial aid i'm in new york
so
there's a lot of that
that's awesome
i'm all for you buying buying some real
estate um
uh but when idiots on the internet say
real estate is passive income
that means they've never owned any
because there's nothing passive about
dealing with renters
and heating heating air that goes out
and roofs that leak and a coach
department shows up and wants to shut
you down because somebody across the
street cut a sewer line
there's nothing passive about managing
real estate
nothing whatsoever you want passive by
mutual fund they'll just put the check
in your mailbox and you won't think
anything about it
but real estate ain't passive
um it's very active
even if you're managing the managing
company they've still got to call you
and approve the 8 400 new heating and
air system that blew up
or the other day i had a 26 000 one go
out on one of our commercial buildings
didn't feel passive to me at all
so
anyway i love real estate but please
enjoy the idea that this is going to be
some hassle factor that other
investments don't have it does give you
a better rate of return that other
investments don't have but when i hear
someone say passive income and real
estate in the same sentence it means
they've been on get rich quick websites
because they make it sound like oh well
the renters will just pay for it uh nope
you're gonna pay for it maybe the
renters pay you
that's how it works in the real world so
you know go buy you some real estate
after you get your life started and pay
cash for it after you get your home paid
off and after you get your 401ks and
other stuff started
but um
this idea that you're going to build a
portfolio of
heavily debt ridden real estate and the
renters are all going to make you rich
is is so freaking laughable that it
makes my head spin
and it's all by people who have never
done it before well you're in such a
good spot right now you went through
college debt-free you're walking
straight into baby steps four five and
six i think that's really where your
focus needs to be right now real estate
can happen someday but focus on
retirement starting out and and get that
primary residence in place and pay that
off once you get to that spot then we
can start talking about really investing
in real estate for profit but you've got
some
very clear steps ahead and if you do
that right you're gonna really
especially at the age you're at right
now set yourself up for success versus
getting kind of lost in this get rich
quick world that's so prevalent right
now like you said on tick tock and
instagram it's like
very very popular but it's also really
leading a lot of new grads down some
crazy routes yeah and sometimes people
misunderstand my sarcasm or anger at
that stuff like it's because it
disagrees with me that's not it at all
it's i know what it's going to do to you
when they mislead you
and you people listening go along with
some of this stupid butt stuff that is
out there
you're gonna you're gonna end up like i
did in my 20s broke
i followed the same siren song
the exact same one only it was just the
1980s version okay and i i and all dave
you just didn't understand listen honey
i uh believe me if there's only if
there's one thing i know how to do it's
numbers okay so i completely understood
and i did it with great gusto
uh starting from nothing in three years
i had over a million dollar net worth
125 properties okay so starting from
nothing in three years so i didn't half
but do it i did it all out i mean you
don't straight out phd and d-u-m-b and
i've knocked it out in a short period of
time you know so and here's the thing i
discovered christine i'd not directed at
him by the way for you sir you are an
engineer which is the number one
of all careers most likely to be a
millionaire when we study millionaires
number one was engineer number two is
accountant number three was teacher okay
so you got a lot of good stuff on your
side just don't fall in to get rich
quick so in our day
they they didn't call it passive income
they called it nothing down
and there was a guy
that wrote the book called the book was
called nothing down it was a
best-selling book
and and a whole bunch of people
including me followed a lot of his
strategies on buying a house with no
money because that's precisely how much
money i had none so that's all i could
use so i used other people's money opm
talk to banking 100 financing 90 day
notes i bought a property made money on
it bought another property made money on
it every time i made money on it the
banker gave me more money it was a nice
formula
and until it wasn't nice anymore
and uh you know a few years later
the guy that wrote the book went into
bankruptcy
ouch i joined a group an investors group
a real estate investors group that were
following this guy's he put together
groups in cities they were following
this guy's guidelines
and got to be friends with a bunch of
guys we would you know one of us we
couldn't do a deal we find a deal we
find somebody else to do the deal we
give it to one of our buddies right and
we swapped it around there was about it
was probably 60 people in that group
that were doing this stuff actively
10 years later
from the time we all started that how
many of them
were still buying real estate and not
broke
none
nobody made it
not
one i take that back
two guys made it but the reason they
made it was they woke up watching the
rest of us go broke and they turned a
whole bunch of their properties took the
equities and paid off the rest they
became debt free and they came out of it
with about 30 percent of the property
but it was all debt-free instead of
leverage to their eyeballs and they they
you know they
re they reverse engineered and got out
with the sk by the skin of their teeth
and i ran into one of those guys the
other day that was 30 years ago he's
still buying real estate and he's still
healthy but he was one of the few smart
enough to look at the rest of us and
going these fools are all going broke
doing the same thing and i was one of
those fools
so you know but you find people get rich
in real estate they're not ones that
leverage up to their eyeballs it's hard
to find somebody follows this passive
income crap
and 10 years later is not broke it's
very difficult to find 10 years later a
real estate investor that follows that
plan
they're they're very rare they're
unicorns but you can still invest in
real estate
i mean cash for it look at you now
i own a bunch of real estate but just
pay cash for it and grow slower and
don't try to go follow all this
mind-numbing get-rich-quick stuff
[Music]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important
you've got to know where you stand so
you make your next move the right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
thank you for joining us america
christina alice ramsey personality is my
co-host today have you ever come notice
that when you commit to change in one
area of your life it becomes easier to
make progress in the other areas
i met a lot of people on their journey
to building wealth who accomplished
other amazing things along the way like
losing 50 pounds
finding a career they love overcoming
stress and anxiety what seems impossible
becomes possible when you have a smart
plan and you turn up the focus and
intensity on your goals that's why we're
bringing smart conference to dallas
texas on saturday october 22nd some of
the leading thought leaders
uh and uh leading thought leaders some
of the thought leaders in every major
area of your life best-selling
authors will be there speaking christina
ellis right to my right number one
best-selling author ramsey personality
will be speaking for the first time at
smart conference
dr john deloney
in the area of mental health own your
past change your future number one
best-selling author ken coleman from
paycheck to purpose on the area of
career george campbell uh one of the
most exciting new ramsey personalities
will be on stage rachel cruz number one
best-selling author three times over
i'll be there and uh craig and amy
grochelle from life church in oklahoma
city will be pastor craig will be
speaking on marriage there october 22nd
it is the only live event with tickets
left this fall
everything else is sold out all over
america thank you america we just came
back from two sold out back-to-back
events in
phoenix arizona a little bit earlier
this week thank you to our ktar
listeners and other folks that came in
for that event we appreciate you very
much
it was uh lights out amazing evenings so
thanks for being with us you can get
your tickets for this
smart conference you'll be smarter it's
all day long it's only 35 bucks you
would pay for more than 35 dollars to
hear any one of these people speak
um that's almost free is what that is
and so october 22nd get your tickets now
uh ramseysolutions.com
events thomas is with us in denver hey
thomas welcome to the ramsey show
oh hi dave hi christina thank you for
taking my call today sure um
i i have to tell you i'm going to try to
get through this call i am definitely
compromised um i've been listening to
you for a very very long time dave and
um i'm 43 and widowed as of eight weeks
ago oh my
unexpected
um
i have a disabled six-year-old daughter
and a ten-year-old boy
and i'm calling because
[Music]
i am just
beyond grateful to you
sorry i'm nervous
and
what happens i can talk to people now
which is okay
what happened to your wife
so
she had an unexpected and sudden heart
attack in her sleep and
i found
i found her
so
our daughter's disabled so she usually
co-sleeps with my daughter and i work
late we were doing the um
we're in the phase of our life where we
have young kids
and she had a full-time job and then i
would work nights and weekends doing
like uber and part-time stuff and i
would take care of her
during the day by my son
and that worked for us and um
so i came home late one friday night
which
excuse me which happens from time to
time
and i really wish i hadn't gone out that
night obviously um not that i could have
done anything but i just would have
liked to have
been home
but um so
in the morning i usually sleep in
because i'm working late
and it was just odd because
i didn't hear the pitter-patter of my
daughter's feet
you know running around the house and
the cupboards and dishes and stuff and i
was like that's weird
and so i i was in a spare bedroom and i
walked in and i heard the kids kind of
giggling
and and i was like huh so i got up and i
went into the master bedroom and
the kids were on the other side of her
playing
and
when i saw mary i
knew right away obviously what happened
and it's like oh my uh just the worst
obviously and i'm so sorry yeah thank
you i i looked at
my boy and my daughter and um
i looked back from my wife and these are
microseconds and um
i he says to me uh
this is daddy i think she's still
sleeping and i
oh that one yeah that one got me um
and then i uh
i picked him up and i
put him into the yeah his bedroom and
shut the door
and i just lost it i couldn't even
hey thomas how long were you all married
uh almost 18 years and together for 23.
um
so
yeah it's not part of the plan to be
voted at 43 right um for sure
so
um
all right let me check this out
so the reason why again i'm calling is
because
i really do think that
if you didn't save my lives you at the
very least have calmed the worst
season of my entire life and i sincerely
thank you and
i
i think his life insurance stuff is
someone that has come in
and
some of it is still being worked out um
i i did the recommended amount that
you'd mentioned
and um i i know what to do that's not my
question today i i know the plan i know
what to do uh we was on we were on steps
four five and six um and you know just
plugging away
and um
and uh so obviously
you know her life is cut short so
everything has changed
but i am taking that
six months to a year
and i'm allowed to do that because of
your plan
so i can i can grieve my my wife now
without having to
you know go to work or yeah or whatever
so
i know i said it but i
i just wish that everybody would really
take to heart because i've i've heard
the call that i'm making right now
dozens of times on your show and it gets
me every time
and i would just say
to your audience
wherever you are right now if you have
life insurance check it check it yearly
to make sure it's in good standing and
it's the amount that you need
and then also um
sit down with your spouse once a year
and go over all the stuff because that's
what mary and i would do i was the nerd
she was the free spirit
and um we would have our budget meetings
um and we got to the point where
you know it was just finely tuned
and i would handle basically everything
and she would i would show her
everything that was going on so that she
was in the know
and um
and i even made a
a spreadsheet dave like i thought i was
going to go first i didn't think it'd be
this early we would have this but i was
like okay mary here's where you go on my
computer you click this and you just go
from you know number or number one to
30. and then this is all of our bills
everything uh our tax person everything
everything everything and so that you
don't even have to think about it you
just just go from one step to the next
um and then you know
that's that was the best so the irony is
i'm following my plan
right
so you're doing the one to thirty
yeah i'm doing the one to thirty
thank you thank you for calling and
sharing your heart i'm so sorry
um yeah um
i i guess that's it i
you and i dave have been friends for a
very long time you just don't know it
um and if you don't believe me you can
ask all my friends they'll tell you all
about it
i'm honored you know so
yeah i'm honored to be your friend and
um yeah thank you i'll tell you i'll
tell you what we're gonna do we're gonna
have kelly pick up and we're gonna set
you up with one of our ramsey coaches at
no charge
just to make sure you're 1 through 30.
um give you uh some other folks looking
over your shoulder
just to love you right now and give you
a hug and um
you know i i bet you're one through
thirty is perfect but uh we'll we'll
walk with you some more here because
that's what friends do
and um but thanks for
sharing your story and i'm so sorry what
a horrible thing to go through yeah i'm
so sorry for your loss and i'm just so
grateful for you calling and kind of
leading that segment and walking people
through what they need to know obviously
that's
you know everybody's nightmare and such
a scary thing but i'm so glad you were
prepared that you had life insurance in
place that you had the one through
thirty and i think this conversation is
going to help a lot of people have that
conversation
with their spouse
one way you say i love you to your
families make sure life insurance is in
place
that's one way you do it
and you know that's true when you sit in
a situation like he is oh my goodness
i'm so sorry
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage andrew
and taylor are with us hey guys how are
you hey how's it going we're doing great
how are you better than we deserve where
do you all live over in frederick
maryland uh closer to middletown okay
wonderful good to have you guys and how
much debt have you paid off we've paid
off 58 123.79
good for you how long did that take
18 months
good and your range of income during
that time about 63 000 up to 85 000.
good well you guys got with it oh yeah
that's pretty impressive what kind of
debt was the 58 grand uh most of it was
student loans uh but we did have a car
loan some tiny medical debts a uh we
even borrowed on a phone and uh of
course you did of course we did yep
wow gotta have those iphones right yeah
that's right
so what happened 18 months ago that woke
you guys up and you said okay game on
well we uh we both grew up in households
that uh you know our parents worked very
hard and they worked very hard they
would often work multiple jobs to make
ends meet but they live paycheck to
paycheck
and
you know they would use credit cards use
all all the loans and everything and um
you know we
grew up as we moved into our
you know early adulthood we did the same
thing we did the same thing that we had
saw sure modeled sure um so we got the
student loans we got the car loans we
got the credit cards all those things
and uh that pursued you know it moved
into our marriage as we you know got
married in 2018
um about two and a half years into our
marriage we looked up and realized you
know we weren't doing
any intentional money goals um and so
you know we would get the money that we
got in every month we'd just kind of
spend whatever we want and then if there
happened to be a few bucks left over at
the end we'd throw that into a savings
account and uh you know after
a couple years of that we had a friend
our friend emily
was the person that kind of plugged the
ramsay bug into our ear she she first
started with taylor and uh you know
saying hey there's this guy dave ramsey
you should probably look into to work in
the plan
and uh that was something that her
family had been working on and so taylor
brought it up to me and i was like you
know i don't know about this he shut it
down yeah i i did shut it down so i was
the one that shut it down uh but around
that same time you know spring summer of
2020 i actually uh decided i wanted to
apply to be a police officer at a couple
of our local uh departments and part of
the application process was actually
listing all of your debts and totaling
it up yep
are you a security risk yeah yeah yeah
and so that i didn't know that at the
time but when that happened um that was
the first time i had done that i never
totaled up my debt i never totaled up
her debt and definitely not totaled up
the two of our debts together and so
when i saw that number on the page oh
crap moment oh crap and so
i felt all that anxiety and that risk
that she had been trying to communicate
to me for those past couple years
and
i i just said that's it game on we're
going to do this
and our finances were separate
and so we just like got married and
we're like oh you know what it's just
easier like i have my own
account you have your own account like
you'll pay these bills i'll pay these
bills like what's your roommate yeah yep
share mustard yeah yeah so so you uh
then the dave ramsey the ramsay bunch
comes back up and you get plugged in huh
yeah yeah so we just started you know
once andrew was on board i was like okay
awesome gay mom but we had never done a
budget before like i don't think both of
our any of our parents were on budgets
and so we sat down and i think what
really got us is we totaled up how much
we spent on eating out and like coffee
and groceries the month before we're
like oh my gosh how is this even
possible we're two people
and so once we sat down um and before
this like sometimes like we thought a
good month was like oh we have 500 left
over at the end of the month let's put
that in savings and i think once we
actually did our budget we had like i
think like 2 500 that was like extra
that we really didn't need to spend and
we were like oh my gosh like what have
we been doing with this two thousand
dollars like before um so we just got
really as you like to say gazelle
intense um and so um we started
doordashing was probably like our number
one side hustle um and so we would work
our normal job 8 to 10 hours and then
pack our food that was like kind of we'd
pack our food for dinner and like go in
doordash to like 10 or 11 o'clock at
night and then andrew did some random
whoever like needed something fixed at
their house he was like oh i'll jump on
that for some extra money and every
dollar yeah so i babysat and um pet set
just kind of whatever but what's the
story on the t-shirts yeah
so so we put these together because um
the why is the most important reason
that we did this because it's not
getting out of debt is a math thing but
it's not just a math thing you can run
the math out all day but the hope the
motivation behind what you do
is the thing that's going to keep going
and keep pushing you forward and so
when we sat down we realized that hey we
grew up in these households that you
know didn't model that financial fitness
they they loved us to death and they
they got us a lot you know and they
taught us an amazing work ethic but
we don't we want something different for
our future kids
and so that hope that was our why and
that's what kept us going on the days
when we were exhausted you know leaving
our normal job and going out to doordash
until midnight or you know for those of
you listening on the radio it says it's
not just a math problem it's also a hope
problem and on the back it says solve
for freedom um
debt free
man you guys are changing your family
tree that is just so cool and i love
that your story you guys were living so
normal before like the fact that you
didn't know what your debts were and you
were shocked when you saw them written
down that you were buying coffees and
doing all these things and you're like
where is my money going so many people
are living in anxiety because they just
have no clue about their money so what
would you tell someone who's in that
space and that mindset of just kind of
closing their eyes and not wanting to
look at their financial situation what
would you tell them to snap them out of
it
i'd say that it's like okay to not be
normal like even once we started our
journey i would talk to friends and i
feel like right we just live in a
culture now that it's like it's all
about me and like i deserve like kind of
like the treat yourself mentality and so
i would talk to friends and they're like
taylor why are you working this hard
like to pay off all your debt and you're
not enjoying like going out to eat like
i would tell people like sorry can't go
like that's not really in the budget
right now and they're like well are you
are you poor and i'm like no like i have
money that's just like not what we're
doing right now and they're like well
taylor like i wanna i work hard so i
wanna spend that money and so i would
just tell them like well we do too but
that's why we're working really really
hard on this goal for the next 18 months
we thought it was going to take longer
than that and then after that then we
can live you know well and you're able
to say that because you like you said
you grew up in a household where you
watched paycheck to paycheck happen year
over year and so now you guys are just
kind of resetting the game you're saying
okay we're going to work hard now so
that in the future our kids can just
have this completely different life than
what we grew up with yeah and i'd also
add to what taylor said just humble
yourself
because if you don't that was the first
thing i had to deal with was me
when that first time i went out and door
dash i was like i have a full-time job
why am i doing this and i just had to
remind myself
i got a goal and this is going to inch
me closer to that goal one step at a
time and that kept me going or like when
we would see people like out like they
would be eating with their families and
i'm kind of like oh no do i hide or do i
like say hi to them you know
so definitely delivering other people's
food that smelled really good when we
weren't eating out was very difficult
but you had a lie you guys are
incredible i'm so proud of you thank you
very well done how's it feel to be free
awesome amazing we have options amen we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story for sure a one-year subscription
or membership rather to financial peace
university and also a total money
makeover book for you to give away and
help somebody get started like you did
like that friend did for you very well
done andrew and taylor baltimore
maryland area 58 000 paid off in 18
months making 63 to 85. rockstars count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two three two one we're debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
that's how it's done boys and girls
this is the ramsey shop
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personalities my
co-host today we know a lot of you are
scared out there with inflation
debt recession
interest rates going up terrified you
won't have enough take care of your
family
well you shouldn't have to live in that
kind of fear
but you do have to get the point where
you say i've had it
and you're ready to make a change when
you get there we can help
the way we help you is the best thing we
do around here it's called financial
peace university
over 10 million people have learned how
to get out of debt
become wealthy and outrageously generous
it's a step-by-step plan
and we're offering it right now at the
lowest price we ever have in 35 years
yeah it's pretty amazing
so stop living in fear you can do this
we can show you how
yeah
not only be debt free but become wealthy
not only become wealthy but become
outrageously generous and change your
family tree
ramsay solutions dot com slash fpu
financial peace university ramsey
solutions dot com slash fpu
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from blinds.com they have
a 100 satisfaction guarantee that means
even if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal
today's question comes from lucy in
florida i'm a senior in college and i
have no student loan debt currently i
have enough scholarships and grants to
cover about 85 percent of my expenses
which include my tuition class materials
and rent out of pocket i pay for my food
toiletries and car expenses i work about
19 hours at 14 per hour a week at a
student position at my college which
covers the other 15 of my expenses i'm
seeing multiple scholarship
opportunities that would apply to my
senior year award letter should i apply
to them the reason i am hesitant is
because i feel comfortable with my
financial situation and i don't want to
take the funds from students who might
need it more than me
even if i was able to get 100 of my
college expenses covered i would still
keep my student position because it's
valuable work experience towards my
future career and data analytics
what should i do
that's an interesting question
i love that you haven't taken out any
student loans i love that you can pay
for your tuition and it doesn't sound
like student loans are on the table so
if you feel comfortable continuing to do
what you're doing and pay for your
expenses and graduating debt-free then i
mean by all means continue doing it the
fact that you're asking this question
makes me think that you feel a little
uneasy with taking the scholarships and
if you don't want to i mean that's fine
but also there's nothing ethically or
morally wrong
for in going for the scholarship so i
really don't think you can go wrong
either way
yeah you're not doing anything wrong by
taking the scholarship you're a very
sweet kind person and you're not harming
someone else
okay go get the scholarship kiddo yeah
go get it put the money in the bank let
it be your
insurance policy that you are able to
finish up school debt-free um you're a
very content person which also means you
have a very high probability of building
wealth
it's one of the big ideas that we push
all the time is contentment
and you're not a greedy person you're
not a person who sets out to harm others
you know or to gain at someone else's
expense and none of that is occurring
when you take this scholarship
none of it is occurring there is
bazillions of dollars of scholarships
that go unclaimed every year
and so you need to go get this
scholarship as many of them as you can
get
and uh you've done nothing wrong by
doing that they're issuing the
scholarship not based on
whether or not you need it they're based
they're basing it based on the
information you give them in the
application right yeah you're not
harming anyone else from pursuing these
great opportunities absolutely open
phones here at triple eight eight two
five
825-5225
anthony is in phoenix hi anthony how are
you
i'm doing great dave how about yourself
sir better than i deserve what's up in
your world
uh so dave i'm i'm really uh kind of
lost right now um just give you a little
background i'm 28 my wife and i have
been married about five years or so just
had a baby in february uh first child
um
with that i
was let go from my previous job and
started uh doing hvac
uh out in arizona
but
having my daughter made me start paying
attention more to my spending a little
bit because i want to set her up the
correct way and you know i've been
looking up how to get out of debt and
you always pop up first so
i just wanted to get some input um i
have about i have the paper here so i'm
i have 19 000 and credit cards
uh 12 5 for student loans and 10 five
for a car
and uh right now i'm doing an
apprenticeship i'm making about 17 uh
but that's supposed to change to about
30
uh coming this next summer uh when i
turn to a service technician so
i really just need some guidance because
it's you know it's something that i i
wait or stay up till two o'clock in the
morning doing bills and
worrying okay you know i know i need
another job it's just more so
i don't know
i don't know where to begin honestly
well i love that you said what really
motivated you to get to thinking about
your finances is that baby because like
you heard in the last debt-free scream
the why is so important and wanting to
change your family tree wanting to leave
a legacy for your child that is an
extremely powerful why
now are you familiar with the seven baby
steps
um just from what i saw i just started
looking at him this week i know that i
think baby step one is saving a thousand
dollars i'm not mistaken so let me ask
you this does your wife work outside the
home
uh she does not she's staying home
with the baby at this time okay then you
are
you're gonna be working all the time
because you're starving yeah yeah 17 an
hour in phoenix arizona for a family of
three you're not going to make it
yes sir
you're not going to make it
so you're going to be working a lot
you're going to be working like three
four extra jobs anything any extra
overtime they'll give you at work for
double pay anything you can do to get
income up got to get the income up got
to get the income up because you're in a
pretty good size hole here with about 40
000 worth of debt and you got a fairly
small shovel right now
yes sir if you're commit to doing that
uh then we'll commit to helping you we
have a whole class that you go through
with your wife
and uh it's a hundred bucks to go
through it but i'm gonna give it to you
free because i've been right where you
are scared broke with a baby
thank you yes oh my goodness they're not
gonna help if i give it to you for free
you've got to go through the whole class
and your wife both of you promise me
yeah
yes i promise you brother okay and so
we'll sign you up for financial peace
university that's what we were just
talking about there a minute ago and you
can take it online you get the class
there and there's a lot of the classes
are taught there in phoenix and local
churches you can plug into one of those
lots of ways you can do the class but
we'll get you sign up it won't cost you
a dime and
what we're going to teach you is to
follow those baby steps that christina
was referring to
get you on a written budget you began to
do that when you're staying up in the
middle of the night worrying and writing
out your bills
that's the beginning parts of a budget
and you start figuring out that there's
not enough coming in
that's why i'm telling you you got to
get more coming in so yeah you're going
to be door dashing and the pizza
delivery you're working extra as a side
gig on
hvac or whatever it is for a while uh
and then when you get to 30 an hour
that's going to help but that's not
going to solve the whole thing
uh even then you're going to still be
going a while
because you've got 40 000 to come up
with to be free because if you don't
have any payments this would be a whole
lot easier you'd still need to get your
income up but it'd be a whole lot easier
and that's where we're going to take you
to so hold on and kelly will pick up and
we'll get you signed up
um you know the interesting thing is
that
fear like that
will move you forward
but too much fear like that will
paralyze you
so you've got to see a light at the end
of the tunnel that's not an oncoming
train
yeah and that's what i was just thinking
when you're talking about how this is
going to be a long journey for him but
there is that light at the end of the
tunnel i love that this call is
following the previous debt-free scream
where it's just such an example of if
you have a strong why and you're willing
to go through that season of hard
it's going to be so much easier for the
rest of your life and for your kids that
beautiful baby that you are fighting for
she's going to know a completely
different world with money
absolutely that's exactly how it works
christina ellis my co-host james anders
zach finn austin kelly all in the booth
helping us out the booth people i'm dave
ramsey your host and we'll be back
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the pods
moving and storage studio it's the
ramsey show where debt is dumb cash is
king and the paid off home mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth through work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life
it's a free call triple eight eight two
five five two two five ned is in fort
bragg hey ned what's up
oh hey how you doing better than i
deserve how can we help
hey so um here's my situation um
basically what happened was uh i've been
in the army a few years during that time
my wife and i got married we had two
kids
uh we bought a property
and uh eventually
we moved out of that property and we now
live on post
um
we rent the property and we make about
400 a month on it now i'm getting out of
the army very soon in the next few
months
we've hit a bit of a rough patch with
our finances and we're wondering if we
should sell the house or not to help us
transition out of the military and it's
civilian life yes
okay
thank you for your service uh but a
rental property
here here's how i made that decision
and how all of us at ramsey process this
i always reverse engineer it
and then that usually gives me the
answer very quickly in the end so by
that i mean let's pretend you did not
own that rental property what what how
much cash would it put in your pocket if
you sold it
uh there's about 100k left on the
property and on the internet it's valued
at 175. okay so let's call it 50 grand
or so okay
you're gonna put fifty thousand dollars
cash in the middle of your kitchen table
in your situation today if you did not
own the rental property and you had
fifty thousand cash in the middle of
your kitchen table would you go buy a
rental property and the answer very
quickly is no
yep no no no because you're
transitioning and you're going through a
rough patch both
right transitioning out of the military
and you're going through a rough patch
with your finances not a time to use
your 50 grand
for a rental property you need to use it
to make this transition proper and to
clean up some of the mess that's causing
the rough patch
does that make sense that's how that's
how i did that sense to me yeah thank
you
thank you for your service what are you
going to do
i'm looking at some options it looks
like i'm probably going to be a prison
guard or a cop
okay
very cool well christina's husband spent
a while in law enforcement she knows
something about that yeah he recently
retired after 17 years so it's been an
amazing career for him yeah
yeah i hope it works out for me too yeah
it's quite the adventure that you'll
have some really interesting stories at
the end of it all
right good for the grandkids yeah that's
exactly right hey thanks for your
service but that's uh that's a good way
to do that
that's that thing we call sunk cost
analysis where you say
you know doesn't really matter how you
got here
you're here
and if you weren't here would you put
yourself back here meaning that okay i
don't want to sell this uh
investment i'm going to wait till it
comes back up that's not how you analyze
it
you know the question is if you wouldn't
buy that investment again today based on
everything you know about that
investment about based on the economy
based on whatever then you shouldn't be
owning it today yeah you should get out
of it yeah and it's good to just have
that reframe because then you can look
at that fifty thousand dollars and say
okay what is the best strategy for this
money what can we do to dig out of this
hole and kind of get a little bit of a
head start and it helps me to just pile
it up visually in the middle of the
table just have like a pile of hundred
dollar bills there fifty thousand
dollars worth of them well and you go
you know what would i really do with
that
and you know sometimes that's a boat
sitting in the driveway that nobody has
had in the water for three years
and you go uh
time to sell the boat
because if i didn't own the boat today i
wouldn't buy it today and if it's worth
eleven thousand dollars or whatever it
is i had eleven thousand dollars piled
up in the middle of the table would i
buy a boat no i didn't put the stupid
thing in the water in three years or of
course i'd buy a boat we use it every
weekend
you know and so yeah then you keep the
boat you can do that with anything right
well sometimes it's things that are a
bit more painful and more painful
situations like we have a lot of people
on the debt-free stage that sold their
truck their beloved truck and it's like
they did see that visual representation
of i love my truck but
that thirty thousand dollars or that
forty thousand dollars that i made that
i shouldn't that i shouldn't have spent
that money on could be a pile of money
on the table that we could use towards
debt and getting i would rather you know
at this point i love my truck but i love
debt free more yep and that's that's
what you're saying when you sell the
truck yep that's what you're saying uh i
remember one of the first times that
happened i had a a good old boy in one
of our fpu classes a big hunter had a
had a big collection of guns and a huge
collection of uh collectible knives it
was a wonderful knife collection
and um
he was a great big old guy you know and
he comes in and his little tiny wife is
sitting there in the we're in the class
and financial peace university we're
having a discussion afterwards you know
in the small group discussion and she
starts crying
and i'm like what's wrong and she goes
my husband just sold his knife
collection to get us out of debt
wow it's the most manly thing i've ever
seen in my life
that he put his family ahead of his
little thing you know and his wife just
she you know she loved him before but
when he stepped up and took care of the
family and her before he took care of
his own little thing it just you know
their their marriage went to a whole
nother level wow and so um but i'll
never forget her crying because i mean i
grew up with a bunch of guys that i know
what that knife collection meant to that
guy some of you are like
you don't understand that was that was
like that was like taking off one of his
little toes i mean you know it's like
it was a big deal
it's so easy to breeze over those
stories and just be like oh yeah they
sold their their motorcycle or their
knife collection and and just kind of
see it as part of the process but like
to do that is i mean i have seen some of
the guys standing on the stage look like
they got punched in the stomach when
they admit that they sold their truck or
something like that but i mean way to go
for doing that because that's just that
is love that is commitment that says a
lot that's exactly what it takes
open phones this hour as we talk to you
about your life and your money we really
value the input from people who watch
and listen to the show it helps us know
what's important to you and the ways
that we can adjust the show there's
parts of the show that we do and we're
really not going to change them
and there's other parts we want to learn
about things we can do to help you
better and uh so we'd love to have your
input we really do
uh so we're doing a survey the survey
takes just a few minutes you can do it
on your phone if you want
and everybody that takes a survey is
registered to win no purchase necessary
someone's going to win a 500 visa gift
card
to say thank you for your time so go to
slash
ramseysolutions.com
and it takes just a few minutes again
ramsey solutions
dot com
slash
survey so uh open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five you can jump in and we'll
talk to you about your life and about
your money christina ellis ramsey
personality is my
co-host today
and uh th this is this is the place
where we teach you to live on less than
you make the concepts we teach here are
not
they're not complicated
not hard to understand
just hard to do
because you got to deal with that person
in your mirror
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the line with us our good friend from
fox and friends steve ducey is with us
with his new cookbook coming out hey
steve how are you my friend
hello dave hello christina from
gorgeous new jersey it's nice to talk to
you hey good to talk to you brother so
you have to come on here every time you
guys do a cookbook because when you came
on with the first one the second one
they were all best sellers and so we
want to make sure that this third one is
a bestseller too and we want to do
everything we can to help
congratulations
well thank you very much dave you know
one thing about what we have seen as we
have come out of the pandemic is when
when everybody was hunkered down
everybody was eating more and a lot of
people were drinking more at home
uh because that's all there was to do
you couldn't really go out now
people are leaving their houses a little
more and they're getting out they still
want to make their own dinner but you
got to make it simple and so that's the
idea behind this cookbook it's it's
based on
simple ingredients
simple to cook and simply delicious now
the simply happy
cookbook by steve and kathy ducey and
actually the secret sauce is named kathy
absolutely absolutely
and i love the sound of simple as a mom
of two that is exactly what i need every
night is something that is simple to
make healthy good for us and can be done
quickly so that's amazing i'm going to
be getting this book
yeah you know the whole idea behind the
series was that it's like the proven
fact it's a scientific fact
that certain foods can kind of trigger
you know the nostalgia department of
your brains and when you see it or taste
it or smell it or somebody mentions it
or you see it on the menu it reminds you
of something happy somewhere in your
past i know
when when my wife kathy makes the pot
roast that my mom made for us
on my birthday
when i walk in the house i can smell it
and as soon as i smell it i am suddenly
eight years old again yeah
that little house in russell kansas and
uh it just takes you that happy time so
it's
it's uh and everybody can identify with
i dave i remember when you and your wife
came on fox and friends and you said one
of your favorite recipes was
an epic pot roast that your wife made
makes with a bottle of wine and it was
fantastic yeah it's amazing yeah throws
a coca-cola in there too if i remember
right yeah it's pretty cool yeah the
smells are you know there's something
really important and we discovered this
again during these times we've all just
come through
about people gathering and gathering and
dining together breaking bread together
is so good
for humans so good for relationships so
good for just your mental wellness the
whole thing and so having a great
cookbook like this to to facilitate that
what what in the world is one of your
favorite recipes and you got stories all
through this thing too it's all about
the stories that tie back to the
different recipes and that that kind of
ties it in like we're talking about with
nostalgia and the relationship right
exactly so every recipe has a story that
explains why it is a happy recipe for
somebody
and one of the motivations we had
to simplify things was because all three
of our kids
including the famous peter ducey the
white house correspondent uh they all
got married this past year and so you
know they'd call and they'd say yeah
we're we're gonna go to the grocery
store you have any ideas simple things
we could cook and of course my wife gave
them some some great ideas
but but you asked about favorite recipes
i i've got a couple of them one
is okay
uh in our first cookbook
one of the primary recipes and everybody
makes a lasagna but my wife made a
lasagna on our first date and at the end
of the first date i said you're going to
think i'm crazy but we're going to get
married will you marry me yeah
it's the will you marry me lasagna
well we call it engagement lasagna oh
okay
40 days well after i told her that she
said thank you that's nice please leave
you're a stalker
40 days later i proposed she accepted
and four months later we were married so
anyway
we did initially engagement lasagna then
with our second cookbook i think the
most popular recipe was
lasagna soup which
is fantastic
and this new one
is
just
wrap your head around this
lasagna
grilled cheese sandwich oh i saw the
picture when i was flipping through it's
amazing
and the other one i like is grandma's
braided bacon
if you have braided bacon
i gotta hold this up that youtube people
can see it braided bacon sandwich
man
i need that so a lot of times when i
look at a cookbook i see these beautiful
photos and i'm like yeah that's pretty
but mine's not gonna turn out like that
how does this cookbook make it less
intimidating for people like me who
maybe my recipes don't often turn out as
prettier as yummy
that is such a good point christina
because so often
um
you know you want to take a picture you
want it
when you're talking to your family you
say dave dave in your cookbook turn to
page 128 if you've got it right there
okay i'll find it um
um
you want to take a picture of of the
food
because it's delicious but it just it
just sits there and so oh my
lord yes yes it is
it's called we call that the iowa caucus
casserole
that is gorgeous
it's cause it's tender tots
the prettiest tater tots i've ever seen
right
is from california but our son peter uh
before he got the assignment at the
white house he was covering all the
candidates in iowa and you know he went
and visited my relatives and they would
have a lot of these casseroles and so we
wanted to put together a casserole with
tater tots from my childhood and so
peter and i worked on this and it is off
the chart good we're gonna make it on
fox and friends tomorrow but
christina it's hard to mess this up when
it comes to the beauty department
because you just make concentric circles
with tater tots and then you put it in
the oven and boom you look like a genius
it looks you know what you know it might
be even a great like appetizer right
yeah the family will be so impressed i'm
liking this okay now is the kid with the
hatchet throwing it at the board is that
you or peter
that would be peter yeah i figured okay
yeah telling my guests that okay
yeah we love you
we love the work he's doing we're proud
of him
oh thank you if you're looking at the
kid with a hatchet if you look two
pictures over dave from that uh that's
me with a broken foot and the the kid in
the monster suit that we made out of
paper mache yeah that is that is the six
foot six inch tall white house
correspondent peter ducey
no shame in your game
maybe in his but
the book is simp the simply happy
cookbook the third best-selling cookbook
from our friends steve and kathy ducey
and uh pretty pretty incredible my wife
has enjoyed all of these christina will
enjoy this one we'll get another one for
sharon as well
and uh
hey little known uh trivia steve for you
christina had a number one bestseller
called confessions of a scholarship
winner she got 500 000 in scholarships a
few years ago before she came on with us
she came on with you guys on fox and
friends and that was her first major
interview and it put that book on the
best seller list she was telling me that
coming in so she was excited to have you
on today
oh that is so nice you know you love to
hear stories like that where
you know you ju when you have a good
idea or something good happens to you
and you get the word out because they i
don't know if you've noticed but there's
not a lot of good news out there it
seems like i've heard something when you
hear somebody who who does well it
everybody wants to learn a secret from
them it's a very full circle moment so
i'm very grateful for that interview and
what you've done and for this cookbook
because i have a feeling i'm going to be
able to cook some very impressive
recipes in there in the near future you
got to do the iowa cockless tater tots i
cannot wait
that one's an absolute must right there
i love it i love it good to talk to you
my friend we'll see you soon next time
we're up there
thank you very much dave and christina
have a great day and make this day a
simply happy day there we go the simply
happy cookbook steve and kathy ducey
check it out the other two are best
sellers for a reason it's a fabulous
stories fabulous pictures all kinds of
great recipes you'll enjoy it we love
this guy i've been friends with him a
long time and thoroughly enjoy uh
promoting kathy's stuff along with steve
so this is the ramsey show
[Music]
christina ellis ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
peter and angelica are with us hey guys
how are you good great hi
welcome welcome good to have you how
much debt have you paid off is a 147
375 and 68 cents i think there you go
good enough and how long did this take
22 months
22 months yes okay and your range of
income during that time it's about 160.
okay what do y'all do for a living i'm a
home care nurse
and i'm a part of legos likes to have my
clinical business as well wow excellent
excellent and where do you guys live uh
about a half hour outside of boston had
some
massachusetts yes okay welcome to
nashville it's a bit of a trip yes all
right good to have you so what started
this whole process to get you guys out
of debt 22 months ago um
well it was started it was about six
years ago we took fpu after we've been
married for about a year and i brought a
lot of student loans credit card loans
into our marriage uh angelica brought a
tiny bit but not not too much mostly was
me
we took fpu
connect church in massachusetts and uh
that started it it took us about a year
to pay that off and then we spent a
couple of years saving up for uh a down
payment
and then um 22 months ago is when we
kind of pulled the trigger with paying
the mortgage off quickly this is your
house yes yes you paid off your house
i'm talking to weird people
that wasn't much of a mortgage no it
wasn't well we put a good down payment
down you know we we followed the baby
steps we did 3b for for a while you know
we saved up our emergency fund in 3b and
then uh got our retirements going and
everything uh with our
with our with our morning we bought
small you know we bought a we bought a
condo we kept conservative you know we
said we want to want to first we want to
be able to have some margins so we want
to pay off the house quickly so good for
you guys wow that's so looked up 22
months ago and said oh let's just go and
knock this out let's do it yeah yeah
keep on the plan just stay on the plane
just stay on the plane exactly wow it
all starts with financial peace
university when you first get married
yeah about a year into it after we kind
of were just looking around without a
plan on how to how to get rid of my
lungs
i just love how much joy is completely
radiating off you all like you can just
feel it before before you guys came on
the stage it's like you could just feel
happiness and that's what it feels like
when you pay off your house when you're
completely debt free it's a whole it's a
whole different world so what did this
journey look like for y'all oh boy do
you want to i don't know well it's hard
at first but we keep always our mindset
with no we have the eyes on a prize and
a final prize and we keep praying and be
focused and we know the budget is
important but we think mindset and pray
and be diligent as a christian we
believe we believe that we have to be a
good steward
and manage god's money well so it's not
ours it's just temporary and
um in 2020 when we we started paid off
the house um ethan was born also
and um was a really tough time was in
march 2018 we hope he was going to be
getting the pandemic yeah yes
isolation and well it's kind of crazy
because peter's a nurse it was really
frightening for me to see you know like
was really really hard but we trust the
plan and say okay we saved some money we
had 20 000
um after he was born and we put it down
right away and then we accelerated it
the remain yeah amount
way to go you guys way to go
powerful
you don't have a payment in the world
what's this house worth today or this
condo a little over 300 okay
yeah
how much in your retirement accounts uh
combined close to one hundred thousand
so we place it we have quarter million
yeah
we're getting there
you're a little over a half a million
net worth now right at it yeah yeah way
to go y'all way to go how old are you
i'm 36 30 38 yeah so 45 you guys are
going to be a millionaire yeah hey
that's what you'll do
okay let's speak it that's so fun that
is so fun who were your biggest
cheerleaders in the process i got to say
my coworker tabitha uh she she became a
dave convert in the middle of our uh
baby step two process two and three um
and uh you know my parents and our fpu
leaders back at connect church um who
else each other yeah
my mom as well i'm from brazil so she
was very excited to see this achievement
i'm here almost 18 years and i came from
less than nothing i just had my
education from brazil and here i met
peter with so much that and i heard
people say why are you gonna get married
and he's so you know so much dead are
you crazy but what he was worth every
penny you know such a man you know like
god man you say he's good looking
i don't know i think i'm married
he's just you know a perfect husband
that you know fallen jesus christ and
that was most important for me than
paying off you know the did that per se
amen well you can get out of debt if you
have a plan yes and uh yeah we tell
folks all the time is we would never
tell someone not to get married because
of debt we would tell you not to get
married if you're not in agreement about
it and you're both in agreement about it
we're going to do this you jumped into
financial peace university knock out his
student loans and then here we go not go
ahead and just finish it up and yes 22
months ago decide oh we're going to do
the mortgage and now we're 100 out and
you're in your mid-30s y'all are in a
great place i'm so proud of you i think
thank you so your mom's jumping up and
down huh
she will when she sees it yeah yes
she's very excited for how i
accomplished well if i switch the
currency in brazil i'm millionaire out
there
multi-millionaire in brazil
that's great it feels great
that'll work too so i like it so for all
the newlyweds who are just starting out
and maybe one spouse is coming into the
marriage with a lot of debt and one's a
little bit nervous about it what advice
would you give them as they start their
journey
oh boy be honest obviously that's that's
one thing that's very important uh
what else
pray together pray yeah prayers that was
a big big thing throughout the whole
process is even though we've got this
plan that we know it's going to work
because you know we've been watching the
show for a while that you've you know
times get tough and you got to pray and
and uh even even getting extra work that
you can handle requires prayer and grace
you know we make our plans and god
directs our steps and uh you do have to
be on the same page
i like that little like eyebrow race
where you're like you gotta be on the
same
[Laughter]
good job you guys i'm so proud of y'all
well done very well done thanks for
making a trip all the way from boston to
celebrate with us we're honored to meet
you and see you and and hear this great
story you guys have got a bright bright
future ahead of you we got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you because
that is the next chapter in your story
in american dollars you'll be there
before you know it and uh
a financial peace membership for the
next year you can give that to someone
that's what started your whole journey
and uh that'll get going and of course a
total money makeover book as well
so let's bring peter in and introduce
him oh it's ethan i'm sorry ethan and
introduce him i'm sorry
and uh so how old is ethan two and a
half oh he's beautiful good looking guy
i'm not surprised very well good stuff
good stuff all right it's peter angelica
and ethan boston massachusetts 147 000
house and everything at 36 years old
making did that in 22 months making 160.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
boys
[Music]
i love it
that is fun
that was amazing that's gotta get you oh
it gets me with the baby i had a
pandemic baby as well to hear their
journey and perseverance through it your
mom is my mom's an immigrant venezuelan
right mm-hmm yeah
swelling and to see her face and that
scream and the jump
that's it ah even the spanish countdown
that's great
or was it brazil's portuguese portuguese
yeah okay but the trestos uno sounds
very similar similar i thought yeah okay
very good very good i love it way to go
you guys that's powerful stuff
so
i don't know what your story is out
there but let me tell you this
you can decide
starting right now
right this second
have a different story
right now you're listening to them you
may not be in the same situation they're
in maybe better maybe worse
but you can decide
you have
the power you don't have to wait on
someone else to fix your life because
guess what they're not going to
it's up to you
pray like it all depends on god you work
like it all depends on you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 91 1
whoever dwells in the shelter of the
most high will rest in the shadow of the
almighty
john mark comer said in seasons of
busyness we need more time
in the quiet place
not less definitely
not less
christina ellis ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five
up next is going to be jan in dallas
texas hi jan how are you
great howdy dave and christina from
dallas good to have you how can we help
thank you so i have to admit i've been
sitting in a lot of fear about
retirement so i do not have family my
whole family passed away in my late 20s
and i'm not married and no kids
and i'm about to be 57 next thursday and
i have 10 000 in 401k so have not done a
great job there
but right now i have 80 000
in cash
and mentally i've thought i would like
to try to buy something outright or
halfway outright so that i don't have a
mortgage and you know just be free of
any monthly payment on housing but i
didn't know if that was the right route
to go or stick that money into mutual
funds and save
uh what do you make a year
so i make 120 000 and then usually have
somewhat of a bonus
okay
all right do you have any debt
i do so unfortunately i have a fairly
new truck that i owe about 31 000 on um
and then i have five thousand dollars on
credit cards right now
okay
i have a feeling the first place to
start is with the truck um
i knew you were gonna say that i'm in
dallas you know you got to have a truck
i know and that's a painful one to let
go
but you are technically on baby step two
and we want to wipe out that debt
quickly and you have the cash to do it
so i mean there is a lot of wiggle room
here's the thing
if you if you don't sell the truck you
got to pay it off
okay today
okay that means you got 50 000 to put
down on a house
okay in dallas
right you're 57 years old
right
when we go get this house paid off
yeah
this truck this truck's a bigger weight
than it feels like it is
it is a big weight right now it's not
really out of line based on your income
but you're late to the game on on
building wealth and getting your house
paid off
uh you got a lot to do in the next eight
years
right you need a paid for house and a
substantial nist egg
and
that truck is incongruent in that story
so you can do it you can pay off the
truck and buy a house for 50 000 down
and pass the credit cards and cut them
up and we'll put you into financial
peace university and start showing you
how to do all this stuff i'll tell you
what let's just do that
okay
and i want you to write on the calendar
the week before thanksgiving do i sell
my truck
by then i want you to have gone through
the nine weeks in financial peace
university i'm gonna give it to you free
you take the class and then you decide
after you see holistically what
christina and i are seeing and it
doesn't sound so arbitrary then then you
decide if you're gonna if the truck is
holding you back from your goals because
i think when you learn to run the math
out on getting a paid for house you see
where i want you to be for retirement is
a paid for house and a pile of money
right
and no other debt either yeah and how
quick can we get there the good news is
you make really good money and the other
good news is you don't have to talk
somebody else into doing all this other
than the person in your mirror
yeah so you can i was gonna retire at
70. yeah just because i felt like i had
to probably do yes you probably did yeah
it's probably going to take you that
long
but just the same um you know what we
need is a 200 000 paid for house by then
okay and and we need you know half
million dollars in mutual funds so we're
seven hundred thousand bucks out of line
and we got 80.
okay and we got you know you got seven
to ten years to do this and i think you
can do it in fact i know you can do it
um
it's just a matter of how far you're
going to sacrifice
because
what you've probably done
because most people do it and just
listening to your story in your math is
you've probably had a really good career
that has incrementally increased it's
probably not been sudden
correct and you've incrementally
increased your lifestyle
faster than your income went up
because you got a 30 000 truck debt and
a 5000 credit card debt so we know you
spent money you didn't have
right and i had a lot of medical debt
over the years yeah yeah yep but either
way you you spent more than you had
coming in
not a ton
until the truck i mean yeah that was the
big one but i mean up until then you've
kind of just but you also didn't save
anything so whatever your increase was
you spent it
correct all along and that's normal
that's not shaming you uh but we got to
have a plan that goes the other
direction now that goes all increases
and
we're going to lower our lifestyle
starting today less than 120 000
substantially because we got some goals
to accomplish here that matter because
the quality of your life in retirement
is going to depend on how much you
sacrifice in the next five to seven
years
you mentioned having a fear of
retirement i hope you hear in this
conversation not more fear but rather
you can follow this plan and
urgency but not fear urgency but not
fear yeah yeah you have a great income
and you've got a solid foundation if you
just walk these steps out with that
urgency you can get there yeah
absolutely you can get there so and
we'll help you jan and you call us back
anytime and you can decide you know
what christina and i are seeing is we
think your life will be better faster
if you didn't have to climb the mountain
without this truck
uh but we'll let you just put that on
the calendar and the week before
thanksgiving you just say a prayer and
say all right god what do you want me to
do well let me do this truck now that i
know what i know from financial peace
university what do you want me to do and
we'll teach you and then you can make
the decision i think you'll come to that
conclusion but i won't i'm still i'm not
gonna be mad at you but i'm just saying
that is one more hurdle one more
obstacle you got to climb over
to get to the end of this obstacle
course you're in that includes a paid
off home
or condo or something
and a pile of money to retire on and we
need to get there pretty quick it can be
done though you make good money and we
just got to get that get that money
harnessed and heading in the right
direction hold on and we'll have kelly
pick up and get you signed up for fpu
shea is with us in jacksonville florida
shea i'm short on time ask your question
quick
shay shay
yeah yeah can you hear me yes how can we
help right quick okay
okay um so i have a question for you um
we are a military family um and just
last year we were doing awesome my
husband and i had over a hundred
thousand dollars in our savings account
we were completely debt free and then we
moved in the military and purchased our
first home
and when we did that we kind of put
ourselves back into debt by
purchasing things for the home
we upgraded our vehicle
and kind of got ourselves upside doing
good and then you lost your mind
yeah we completely lost our mind and how
much debt have you got all on me how
much debt have you got don't don't i
only want to tell you because i know
you're going to yell at me but um we owe
on my husband's car about 18 000 on his
and we owe we just got a new van and we
owe 47 on that yeah you need to sell
that that was dumb
and i knew you were going to say that so
my question is how do we even go about
doing something as far as
selling how much money have you got 100
000 still in savings
so right now we currently have 60 000
left in savings and that's after putting
down the down payment for the home yeah
and your household income is what
um right now we're at like right at a
hundred thousand
um
you can you got the money to sell the
van sell the van and go buy you a van
that's 10 or 15 000 to haul your kids
and
you're gonna have to stop this you're
not you're not in congress you can't
spend like this
yeah i know
i had is
i did something else stupid that i know
you're gonna yell at me about i'm not
gonna yell at you about anything honey i
love you i want you to win i appreciate
your service to the country uh and we'll
put you guys through financial peace
university and help you get out of this
but honey you ain't gonna be able to
keep this van
it just doesn't fit and you know it in
your heart of hearts you know you can't
do this it's not me yelling at you i
don't want you to win i just love you i
want you to do good
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
audience survey for the ramsey show and
we'd love your feedback you could be
entered to win a 500 visa gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey
[Music]
you